welcome to the uh fourth lecture in this
class couple of logistical things one
your homework one was due yesterday um
you have a late day budget if you
haven't finished it you have a total of
four late days so another I guess two
days that you can use on one homework a
total of seven for the semester you Ed
four of them now you only got three left
for the other three homeworks combined
so no you do what you have to do um one
little thing to flag Maybe homework is
designed to take anywhere from 20 to 40
hours um if it takes you uh less than 20
hours that's great you're going really
fast um if it takes you more than 40
hours you're not asking for enough help
or you just don't have the right
background so keep that in mind if you
see yourself busy let's say 100 hours on
one homework uh please come ask for help
uh more frequently and and
sooner any logistical questions oh
actually one other logistical thing uh
the register increased the class size
and so everybody who was on the wait
list was moved in um I know
undergraduates and concurrent enrollment
students cannot make it on the weight
list so they're still out um but we
dropped a note on ad stem let us know if
you're undergrad or concurrent
enrollment you still want to get into
the class send us an email on the staff
mailing list and we'll take a look at
your homework one and get a sense from
that whether to request for you to be
admitted into the class or
not
okay
yes well sometimes you have to sit and
wait a little bit I guess it depends
yeah I guess you could inter leave it
you could you know get something going
and then do something else um but let's
say you just kind of non-stop worked on
it you type you wait you type you wait
something like that
m
okay today we're going to cover latent
variable
models
so just to give a bit of context we've
looked at autoaggressive models we've
looked at flows in which case in some
sense all the random variables were
observed were very directly modeling the
distribution over X um and that'll be
different
now in Laten variable models we will and
some have the assumption that maybe
there's a lower
dimensional piece of information that
really encodes what is incarnated in X
and if we can capture that lower
dimensional simpler representation Z
then that's a much more compact
representation to represent the data and
in that space it might be easier to do
things like interpolate between data
points or it might be a good way to
compress the data of course or could be
a good representation to then learn a
classifier on top or yet do other things
with so autog Rive models looked like
the model on the left Laten variable
models will look like this flow models
looked a bit like this too but in flow
models the Z stayed in the same
dimensionality as X which limited it a
little bit in what it could do um here
we won't be making that assumption and
will be other uh important differences
so bit more motivation um by example
imagine you want to represent this image
um one way to think of it that is you
know pixel by pixel representing the
image another way to think of it is hey
was a corgi on the left which is red and
white there's another Corgi more towards
the middle which is also red and white
and has a floppy left ear um there's a
third Corgi all the way on the right
which is trollar and then and in the
background there is a wood bench and
it's in a
park and maybe what I just described is
something you'd want the model to
somehow naturally know about I'm not
saying we're capable of doing that fully
with the models we covering today or any
models for that matter but the Hope
could be that a good generative model
would be able to take an image
effectively projected onto the
explanation I just gave and then
reprojected back out to what you see in
this
image so wet and VAR models from a you
know more complete uh perspective
compared to autoaggressive models
autoagressive models are slow to sample
because all the pixels that is
observational dimensions are assumed to
be dependent on each other so you have
to wait for the previous pixel to be
sampled to be able to sample your
current pixel as you know from the
homework you can do caching which means
you don't have to do at least any repeat
computation but you still have to wait
till the sampling is done of the
previous pixel before you can fully
sample the next
pixel
um even if there is no true
independencies across the pixels it
could be that they are conditionally
independent condition on some side
information like the description of
what's in image for example exactly what
the Corgi uh what the corgis look like
could be independent of each other um
given we know that there are corgies in
certain locations whereas if we just
have a pixel level model we'll only know
where these corgis are once the pixels
are being generated we'll only know then
that they're not overlapping or are
overlapping and so forth and so having
that higher level information can
actually tell us actually the way you
render these three corgis is decoupled
in this case because they're separated
from each other in the
picture um and the hope is that if
somehow we can capture that lat and
structure um things can lead to better
representations but also can have faster
sampling because you just sample Z and
then from there you can generate the
entire X you don't have to wait for the
previous pixel to generate the next
one um sometimes it's possible to design
a Laten variable model by hand
effectively with an understanding of the
causal process that generates the data
like a special case of this be maybe you
could have a um latent variable model
that is hardcoded where maybe your
decoder is a graphic hent right how does
Graphics work traditional Graphics you
describe the objects that you're going
to be rendering you describe their
coordinates and the render turns that
into an image you can imagine that all
that description of what's going to be
in the scene that's your Z and you can
then hope that maybe you can learn an
end coder from image into Z and then the
decoder is hardcoded that's your causal
process that you understand how
rendering happens and in fact towards
the end of class or the end of not this
class but the the course we'll have a
guas electron Nerfs uh neural Radiance
fields and it's a bit like that it's
assumed that rendering happens in a
succession where things in the back then
things through the front uded things in
the back and so you can have um stronger
priors over how scenes are set up so I
think it is interesting to keep thinking
about that clearly nerves are some of
the no most interesting recent
approaches to to generating imagery
while the lat representation knows more
about what's what's happening behind but
today we're not going to assume any of
that we're not going to assume any
specific structure like oh a graphics
engine we turn it into a scene we're
going to hope that it just emerges from
the
data
so as you know from previous lectures I
like to start very simple the simplest
version of each mod model and build up
from there so what's the simplest
version of a latent variable model there
is X is our
data so X is a data point and then this
Z is our latent and in this lecture Z
will always be the latent and that's
pretty common in in the literature and X
will be the
data so in this specific model um in the
very simplest case k equals 1 you just
sample a single variable that could be
zero or one coin coin TOS effectively
takes one value or the other value and
then condition on that you generate X
which um could let's say be some you
know bar new so also 01 variable that
maybe comes after some deep N Net
processing on Z you come out with a
sample uh distribution for x and use
sample
x z could be Vector valued so it could
be multiple 01 variables that to getter
encode information about the scene or
could be other type of data um I'll
often talk about images because easier
when when it's very concrete to think
about this but so for Z you could say is
there a car present in the scene or not
is there a dog present in the scene or
not all these things could be sitting in
Z and then the neural network turns that
into an image X that incarnates those
pieces of
information so
the way you work with this model you
sample from pzz actually pretty similar
to flow models last week in that regard
um that gives you your Z and then from
there you sample your X from P Theta x
given Z the way these models are going
to be set up is that um consistently
we'll choose a distribution pz that's
easy to work with that's easy to sample
from and we'll also choose distribution
P Theta of x given Z that's easy to work
with B Theta x given Z will typically be
a deep neural network that processes Z
into then an output distribution for
X to evaluate the likelihood you just
evaluate this over here note that unlike
with flow models where there was
essentially Z oneon-one mapped to a
corresponding X um and then we had that
log determinant scaling factor to
evaluate the likelihood to account for
how volumes change in the transformation
here it's a bit different how it's set
up this is assuming discrete you see the
summation the probability of a certain
value for x is the sum over all possible
Z so Z can take on 100 values you have a
sum over 100 terms there the probability
of that particular Z multipli with
probability of x given Z so X in
principle be caused by multiple Z's that
each cause this x to emerge possibly um
so that's that's the
model as expressed exactly then to train
you maximize the log probability of the
data so I indexes into data points so
maximize the sum of the log
probabilities of each data point XI and
if you expand it so we're really using
this thing here to get this expression
here this is what you
have note that even though there's a
product of probabilities here and
there's a log we cannot split it up
because there's a sum there it's a log
of a sum of product of probabilities
it's not a log of a product of
probabilities so this this sum prevents
us from just making just a just a log of
sum of
logs okay so then if we want to get the
representation for a data point we feed
in X and get out Z we'll want something
for that too um in Principle as we look
at the model here and we'll start with
that you can just use base rule right we
have pz we have PX given z um we can
find pz given X using base rule right p
z given x equals P um x given Z times pz
over PX
right
now it does turn out that this is not
necessarily easy to compute but in
principle mathematically that is the
answer to your question um but a lot of
work we'll do is actually realizing that
this is a bit intractable this summation
here can also be intractable and how to
deal with that but so but in principle
in a small scale scenario we can go in
either direction quite easily and do it
exactly Okay so we've seen some
motivation and the very basic kind of
underlying model we're going to be using
um now we'll look at how to train them
uh we'll look at exact scenarios then
we'll use that sampling based scenarios
then we'll look at the variational lower
bound and uh other name for the same
thing the evidence lower bound we look
at how to optimize the objectives that
we uh propose and then we'll look at
many variations so the first part of
lecture will be all about getting the
formulation correct essentially the
algorithmic part and the second part of
lecture will be about getting the
details right about what really should
be the ne net architecture that you put
in place such that this thing actually
succeeds actually the second part Kevin
you're going to be giving that part you
knew that
um um
so starting with training these
models so scenario one base case to
understand the simplest case that could
come up um Z can only take on a small
number of
values which
means the exact objective is tractable
that summation becomes easy to compute
because as I said we're going to assume
pz is simple to evaluate and Sample from
and this case don't even need to sample
we just enumerate all these and then P
Theta x given Z again with by Design I'm
going to choose it to be something easy
doesn't need to be computationally cheap
could be a very large NE Network going
from Z to X but it's something that is a
straightforward calculation uh that we
can do so the exact objective is
tractable then we can just directly
optimize it scenario two Z can take an
impractical number of values to numerate
so we need to approximate
you might wonder how about optimizing PC
learning the prior actually it's
sometimes done and we'll see examples
later and Kevin gets into the details
that we can also learn pz at times on
the one hand you might say I don't want
to learn pz because I want my data to go
from whatever complex distribution it is
into a simple space and how can I force
it to land in a simple space is by
deciding what pz is if I make pz simple
enough then somehow the data is forced
to be somehow the data distribution is
forced to morph into this simpler space
where presumably um it's more meaningful
when embeddings are close together that
means the images are very similar which
for example wouldn't necessarily be true
in directly in pixel
space now you can go very extreme and
often you know at least in early goings
people will say let's make pz a gausian
or um just binary random variables for
pz
little harder to optimize when pz has
discret valid random variables but it
can be done um but gusan is maybe the
most Natural Choice
um it can be still a little restrictive
you might want something that can model
just a bit more than just a gaussian in
the embedding space why is that if it's
just a gausian every latent variable is
independent so go back to the example I
said earlier when I said is this
variable saying no whether it's a dog or
not another one saying is there a cat or
not that that's kind of Our Hope right
another one is saying is there a horse
or not another one is saying is there an
airplane or not another one is saying is
there a desk or not and so forth you
could expect that in your data there are
correlations there that maybe when
there's a dog it's maybe a little more
likely there's maybe another dog than
when there is no dog or maybe when um
there is a car that might be likely
another car um because it might be a
street scene with many cars and so forth
and so if you're just force pz to be a
gausian you force every variable in the
zspace to be independent which means
you're not capturing such dependencies
so even though simple is desirable too
simple might just not allow you to
achieve a good model of your data so
there are some trade-offs
there okay so let's look at a very
simple example we're going to model a
latent variable model where X is you
know uh let's say think even like just a
two-dimensional Vector X is where your
data lives and there are three values Z
can take on and X is distributed
according to a gan multivaried gaussian
conditioned on Z so it's just a mixture
of Gauss if k equals three which we'll
see on the slide next um this is just a
mixture of three Gs distribution that
we're modeling here and then the
training objective becomes maximize
Theta the parameters of this model in
this case um we fixed the mixture
coefficient we fixed the prior so each
gaussian bump is equally likely to be
occurring and then for each gion we can
learn the mean and the ciance in this
case very simple we obviously don't need
um you know special lecture on Laden
variable models is all we're going to do
but I think it's a good starting point
so if we train this model let's say with
gr and descent um on the top left we
have the training data then um we train
the model but epox Zer is just randomly
initialized we sample from it from our
three gaussians and we see that yes we
get three clusters because there three
gaussians in our model but they don't
land in the right spot as we go through
multiple EO of training we see that
these three gaans actually shift to the
three modes of the distribution which is
in this case naturally what we'd be
hoping for and we have a very good model
of this very simple data set but it is
essentially all that's needed here and
it's the beste case any questions about
the simple scenario
here okay let's keep
going now what if Z can take on many
values okay not three values like we
just saw but maybe millions of values
maybe even more imagine Z is continuous
then it can take on infinitely many
values or if Z is discrete and there is
01 variables is 100 of them that's two
to the 100 possible values your Z Vector
can take on you cannot enumerate all of
those as you try to evaluate the
likelihood but because we know Z comes
from a distribution and this summation
here that's just an expectation with
respect to Z we can just replace that
expectation with samples from the Z
distribution and so this part
here
becomes effectively this thing over
so for
each term here um here on the left there
could be I guess too many to handle here
we take some c k that that's reasonable
maybe we take for each XI each data
point XI we take 10 samples Z and then
um put those terms in in there
then you can run stochastic and descent
on the approximate objective um and
every EPO you can resample your z's if
you want to and hopefully um this
approximation will do well for
you now the challenge with prior
sampling obviously when you do prior
sampling it's nice it's simple all I
need to do a sample from Z you have a
clean objective to optimize
question you choose the B here or do you
get it from the you
know yeah so the question is what is Big
K um it's a hyperparameter that you can
choose because the more I guess Z's you
sample the longer it takes to evaluate
this objective and to then do a gradient
step um but then also in some sense the
more precise the approximation is
whereas then the smaller your K is um
the fast you can evaluate and get a
grade step so it's a bit like you know
it's almost like batch size it's a it's
it's a bit of a parameter like that
mhm yes
question um is this an unbiased or
biased estimate of the
objective um
well the this
part is an unbiased estimate of this
term here like it will have the correct
expectation um
now after you apply the log um I'm not
sure I'll I'll leave it to you to think
that through um I don't I don't have the
answer top of my head but the part that
you're replacing has the correct
expectation probably
not yeah the nonlinearity might make it
um by it's
possible what is true is that if you
sample infinitely often you will get the
correct objective so if you you're
willing to sample infinitely often this
is um the correct objective you just
don't have the time to do
that and in fact it's even more tricky
than that imagine you're trying to model
some data right um we have some data
points X in in 2D some others are here
some others are
here bunch of data
points and so in this case there is 2 4
6 8 9
nine clusters effectively
right
now imagine I'm doing a pretty good job
with a mixture of gions I got lucky I
chose nine mixture components so I'm
going in the scenario where everything
is going my way right there's nine
mixture components these mixture
components land pretty much in the right
regions so everything's going my way and
now I sample my Z okay let's say this
here is my x side that I I currently
care about and I'm going to Now
sample sample
Z if I sample Z
from the
prior then I have equal probability to
land on any one of those nine
clusters and
so only one in nine times on average
will my Z land in the cluster that
corresponds to this XI every other time
it will effectiv put us in another
cluster and if my Z lands over here for
this cluster then under this you know
the gaussian bum that's sitting here the
probability of X is sure there's a
little bit of a contribution but it's
near zero because it's so far away and
so when I look at
evaluating these sums here 1/ K sum from
1 through K of probility of x given Z
most of these terms will be near zero
not really contribute and then the one
out n times I'm lucky I'll have a term
that contributes and so when I'm doing
the training I'm essentially wasting
eight out of nine of My Cycles really
should have chosen 10 10 uh mixture
components but uh I'm losing eight out
of nine of my compute Cycles on terms
that are essentially useless for
modeling the
data so that's a tricky tricky part here
in this case it was I would lose eight
out of nine but imagine your Z is 100
dimensional there 2 to the 100
possibilities and a specific X might
only match up with one or two out of
those two to the 100 possibilities and
now you have zero chance to get the
correct C and all your terms will
effectively be zero and contribute
nothing to the objective and so you're
just busy busy busy never getting a
lucky Z and never getting any signal so
clearly I mean the intuition here is
that we shouldn't just sample Z from the
prior we should make sure that we get
get Z that are correct for the X's that
they're going to be paired up
with so um
now to to formalize this a little bit
let's do a little side Sid track on
import sampling because that's what
we're going to want to use here so in
important sampling let's say you want to
compute an expectation of a function f
of Z where Z is sampled from pz but it's
hard to sample from pz or the samples
from pz are not very informative so
those are the two scenarios where
important sampling is very relevant
scenario two is our scenario I'm not
going to go into scenario one but just
so you know that's another case where
important sampling can come in
handy so a very simple example for um
two is imagine I
have a
pz
that maybe
looks like this right similar to what
we're talking
about and then maybe uh my f of Z looks
something
like this okay then really what I what I
want is I really want samples over here
which I'm naturally not going to get
when I sample from pz because there's
not a lot of probability there but those
are the only terms that contribute to
that expectation or meaningfully
contribute to the expectation that's
when I just sample from
pz most of my samples go to
waste same thing was happening over here
this P Theta x given Z most would go to
waste that's the counterpart of that
function FC I was drawing on the slide
over
here okay what's important sampling I'm
interested in expectation with respect
to
pz I know that's what I care about but I
know that I want my samples to fall over
here if I want to go force my samples
over there obviously I'm not sampling
anymore from pz so I'm going to
introduce a correction factor for what
I'm doing an important sampling gives us
the formalism to get the right
correction factor in
place so this is the expectation we're
looking at we multiply and divide by Q
which is the distribution we're going to
be sampling from that is also easy to
sample from and hopefully will be
focused in the area we care
about then we call this an expectation
again because the qz at the top here sum
over Z qz expectation with respect to
qz um and then we say oh we have an
expectation again now where we sample
from qz instead of from
pz and now we sample and this is our
sample approximation when we sample from
qz and we see that we have a correction
factor here here was the ratio between
pz and qz so whenever qz is very high
and pz is very low will weigh things
down because it's places where qz is
putting a lot of samples but pz wouldn't
have done it and the other way around
um in the example I just described
really what would happen is usually we
get weighted down because we're going to
put our samples in a place where pz is
low we're going to explicitly put them
there and then we're get weighted down
but at least we have meaningful samples
that we care about that give us signal
as opposed to putting them where pz was
high and we get nothing in terms of
signal for
FC so this can always be done by the way
any anytime you need to compute
expectation with respect to one
distribution you can choose another
distribution and then use that uh
correction factor the ratio there to uh
to account for sampling from the other
distribution so in our lat variable
model what does that mean we have that
expectation over here over Z's we
replace that with a sampled version
where we sample from Q which is an
alternative distribution and then we
have the correction factor right there p
over Q what would be a good distribution
for qz because now we have a new
hyperparameter in some sense what qz are
we going to choose to make this work
well well how about
the Z that is the Z's that are
essentially most likely given the XI I'm
trying to model right now that seems a
pretty Natural Choice and in fact later
we'll formally see that's the best
choice um but just intuitively it also
is a natural choice to choose that and
so you can use base rule to come up with
what that uh distribution is for z um
and then hopefully you can sample from
it um but likely it's not so obvious uh
how to sample from it because
essentially the expression
here is not a distribution you can
easily sample from um it's this you know
multiplication of different things and
that's very different from just sampling
from let's say pz which is just a
distribution you choose but here you
have a simple distribution multiply with
a neural network that gives you
something over X and you divide out the
probability of X which and by the way
this thing is actually this complicated
thing up here that you're already having
trouble modeling so we're going to do
more we have to do more work to get
anywhere near that but that's idea we're
going to sample from some qz that
hopefully gets close to
this so how do we find a qz that's close
to what we want uh the variational
approach to doing this says we can't
directly use the P that we want so
instead we propose a parameterized
distribution Q we know we can work with
easily which in this case means sample
from easily and try to find a parameter
set that makes it as good as possible so
maybe our qz will again be a
gaussian but there will be a gussan that
we try to move as close as possible to
this posterior which we really would
want to sample from I haven't said yet
how we move our qz in that position but
that's going to be the
goal now one natural solution and is say
okay I'm going to find a qz that
minimizes the K Divergence between qz
and P Theta Z given XI so I'm looking at
a very specific data sample XI I'm going
to do that for every sample different qz
for every one of them I have my sample
I'm going to solve this optimization
problem obviously we're still working to
the final solution we're not going to
want to solve an optimization problem
every data point separately but as we
work to our solution we're now solving
an optimization problem a k Divergence
minimization to find a really good qz
the mean and the variance of a gaussian
let's say that brings qz as close as
possible to P Theta Z XI now we said
this thing P Theta isn't easy to sample
from Z XI um how can we even count on
that this K being easy to optimize well
let's unpack it um this thing here well
the K is the expected log odds ratio so
just the definition of KL going to line
two then we unpack this posterior of Z
given XI into the denominator here same
thing as on the previous slide just base
rule um then we since it's a product
and uh division of multiple
probabilities and there's a log in front
we can just make it a summon sub
addition and subtraction of logs of
these things and we get this thing over
here now let's take a look at all these
terms the last term is actually pretty
tricky log P Theta XI is a distribution
we're trying to model is a thing that we
are very hard having a very hard time
getting a handle off
but
um it turns out that um if
you if you look at the um interaction
here there's no the Z doesn't explicitly
appear here is just something that's
independent of Z and so the expected
value of something with respect to Z of
this thing is just some constant our Q
does not affect this because our Q our
distribution over Z always sums to one
no matter what and so it's not going to
affect what we end up over here it's
always going to be that number whatever
it is we just don't know the number but
it's going to be the same number no
matter
what the terms that do have qz in it
either implicitly or explicitly the z's
are in there um we have to work with and
so this is the
minimization that we have to
solve let's look at these terms log qz
we chose qz to be easy to work with so
that should be easy to evaluate pz given
Z we chose pz to be easy to evaluate and
work with so that's again an easy term
and P Theta XI given Z we also chose to
be easy to work with um in practice the
qz might be a gaussian pz given Z might
be another gaussian and P Theta XI given
Z might be a neural network mapping from
Z to a distribution over X and so now we
have this optimization problem here
where every term is easy to to work with
we can solve for the optimal qz once we
found the optimal qz we can sample from
it and use the important sampling
adjustment to compute the expectation
that we want to then uh continue with
our latent variable modeling so a lot is
going on but at least we understand that
we can do
this
now right now for all XI all data points
XI we would be solving this this Cale
minimization problem which is you know
we're solving this big optimization
problem every step along the way just to
generate the samples that we want for it
we have to solve an optimization problem
in the in Loop for every data point
that's just too much so what people do
they amortize this meaning they say well
instead of finding let's say a separate
mean and Co variance for each data point
XI to match the posterior for Z instead
I'm going to set up a neural network
let's say that maps from X space to Z
space and predicts the right mean and
coant corresponding to that XI um and
now you have one optimization problem
where all of these participate in but
it's only one problem you parameterize
your distribution differently right so
here you effectively are trying to solve
for
mui Sigma I for all data points
I here you're just solving for fi
what is fi well fi will typically be a
neural network that helps you map from X
to Z what is I really mean map from X to
a mu that depends on X and a sigma that
depends on X all parameterized by
f um so you can effectively reuse learn
the pattern of what Z you want to end up
with also to be clear you might not
actually output Sigma here um you might
output a diagonal version of it and you
might I'll put log Sigma instead of
Sigma to not have to deal with the fact
that things need to be um positive and
so forth but conceptually the key idea
here is to go from solving many problems
for many individuals mui Sigma I to get
with these and by the way you still then
have separate mu and sigma I they just
come through the neural network because
if you feed in x i you actually do get a
different muxi and a different Sigma XI
out for different XI it's just that it's
parameterized and so the ne Network
tells you the answer rather than running
this optimization every single time to
get the mean and variance yes isn't
isn't the posterior changing with
respect TOA as well so like ASA
changes so it's a good question
um as we solve this and try to find our
Q it's the Q at topal depends on the
current choice of theta which is
something we're learning and so as you
update Theta you also again have to redo
it find a new Q now the beauty is if you
make a small update to Theta probably a
small update to five and so you you kind
of alternate between them um and move
them in sync along um but yeah that is
part of what happens you have you're you
be doing an alternating optimization
between the Theta and the FI and when
you have your new fi you can sample your
z's you can use that to construct your
objective for Theta and then update your
Theta and go
again oops skipped over something I
think yeah so pictorially I mean we went
through a lot of math and there's a lot
of math behind the scenes pictorial it's
often just described this way you have a
z which we have P Theta x given Z goes
to X and then you have a network qf that
Maps back in the other direction and
we're solving this problem here while
you know plus we're solving
Max over Theta su/
I log B
Theta XI which by the way expands into a
sampled version of you know XI depending
on on Z that was
sampled now what could this be as I said
qf um essentially outputs a mean and a
variance or equivalently we could um
um you know say that Z is equal to a
mean that depends on X plus some Epsilon
I get sampled from normal distribution
unit normal and then multiplied with the
variance so that's how you can get an
actual Z out from such a
network okay so this gives us the first
version of the vae the variation Auto
encoder specifically the importance
weighted a encoder um our
objective right is the sum over all data
points that's I the log probability of
that data point this thing here is our
approximation of P
Theta x
i which really is you know integral or
sum over all Z of
pzz time P Theta x i given Z but again
we don't want to enumerate all Z's so
instead we are sampling Z's we're
correcting for the fact that we're
sampling from Q instead of pz and then
this term is still there at the same
time to make sure this is actually
effective the Q that we use is one
that's helpful in uh getting signal to
optimize P Theta we also minimize this
k um might seem know kind of funny that
with just two optimizations now but
that's just the way it comes out in fact
we go further in lecture you'll see with
some alternative derivations you just
end up with effectively the same two
terms you just add them together and
optimize both as one objective um it's
just that one side depends on the Q5 and
the other side depends you optimize the
qf and the other one optimize the P
Theta so you can just put them together
maximize term one minus term
two
any questions here because in some sense
this is the basic version of everything
we're going to cover today if this is
clear you're in really good shape if
it's not clear it's a good time to ask
questions
yeah
have and then
the amate problem you
have right down
here work with
paramera and instead of get and problem
reverse yeah that's a good question what
does p Theta Z given XI mean in the
notation I'm using here there's no
neural network associated with that so
all there is is there is pzz there's P
Theta um x given Z and there is um
qf Z given X those are the the only
things that we have available to us and
when I write P Theta Z given XI really
what I'm writing is um or should be
interpreted as applying base rule
meaning I'm writing
[Music]
P um C given x i * p x i over p z to
make this more precise add in um
hold on I did that the wrong way let me
because I'm ending up with the same
thing at the top which is not what I
want
um I'm
writing so base R flips it it would be x
i given Z with a Theta here pzz divided
by um
P um x
i
and um is just saying that you know I
applied Bas rule using the original
distribution that I'm looking to uh find
it's not saying that there's a neural
network that incarnates this direction
in some sense we want that neural
network and the qf is the one that's
doing it for us um that's the one that
actually does go in that
direction
yeah
um this also has a five in it
absolutely
um correct yeah if let's make it more
complete we we could write a
conditioning bar here condition on XI
that's right MH thank
you and then same thing here as we're
sampling this would be conditioned on
XI great Point yes I I might have missed
something but it's interesting that in
the second term I think the term that
you removed was P Theta of M and in the
objective you just add that term back
but you're just ask me is that did I
miss something or is that so technically
like the second objective had everything
you needed it had the top term just like
not in
theion yeah that's that's a that's a
good observation and you'll see that
come back later that
um when we removed it it was because
we're just optimizing over fi and it was
no f it but you're right it was there
and if we were going to optimize also
over Theta then we could just kept it
but um yeah I wouldn't worry about it
for now but it's a good observation
you'll see it come back
later okay um now there is some theory
in the iwa paper that shows that the
more you sample your z's the more tight
on expectation your bound will be it's
actually a bound and it becomes Tighter
and Tighter as you get um more samples
now the tradeoff is the more samples you
get for your z's the more work you spend
on those samples the more work you do
for effectively one gradient update and
so less gradient updates for the same
compute budget so it's a trade-off how
many do you really want in one pass but
let's say you have highly paralyzable
compute infrastructure then maybe you
sample as much as you can do in parallel
put it all in there and then you have a
more accurate estimate than if you
didn't do
that okay then skip skip these two you
can look at them offline if you want um
now let's look take a look at a
somewhat different way of getting to
roughly the same idea
um
and what I mean with that is
that
um in the end effectively we'll end up
with the same thing um uh if we only
sampled once instead of K with this new
derivation
um but it also turns out and I think the
new derivation is less intuitive it's
more like a derivation where like if you
know the answer then you can get to it
quickly derivation rather than a very
intuitive explanation um but it is the
one that people often use in papers and
so forth because it's like a much
shorter derivation to get where we want
to be and it is a correct derivation but
in the end I think the intuition that we
just build up is the right intuition and
gets us where we need to be but let's
derive it in the in the shorter version
I guess um right
now so let me I think I actually have it
on the next slide and since
we we have a lot to cover let me let me
just use it as written already and so we
can go through it just a little bit
faster here is what we're trying
to do again so just be clear we're solv
the exact same problem we've been
solving so far which we actually solved
we're done in some sense except that
most papers you're going to read are not
going to derive it in that intuitive way
at least I think more much more
intuitive way they're going to derive it
this way um okay so then we say okay if
that's what we're interested in and we
know that it's really a sum over Z of pz
time P Theta x given
Z then we multiply and divide by
qz no mention of important sample but
obviously there's a strong connection
there is the same idea um I'm gonna go
through it first before I get to your
questions oh zoom in okay how about this
way oh great yeah much better I agree
much much better
nice um so it's not coincidence there is
a multiply and divide by qz but in this
derivation it just comes as a random
trick um then you expand it
um and you use a bound to do the next
step so what you have
here sum over Z qz at the top that's an
expectation with respect to
qz um we have a log up front when you
have a log of an expectation you can't
simplify things um you want to bring the
log on the inside to simplify all those
things multiply together will become a
sum we simplify things we want to swap
the order of the log and the expectation
so what do we do we apply gance
inequality which says that the log of
the expected value of x is bigger than
the expected value of the log of
x I'll show that to you by example so by
example say I have two x's I have X 1
and
X2 and so I have
correspondingly log
X1 and
log
X2 and on the left here I have the log
of the expectation let's say it's an
equal distribution half weight on X1
half weight on x2 and expected value of
x is right in the middle it's going to
be right here that's my ex okay I can
look at the log lands right
there that's this side now for the other
side expected value of the log of x half
the weight is on this half the weight on
that we got to average that pictorially
averaging that means we draw the line
and take the point in the middle and we
see the Green Point in the middle lies
below the red Point that's above it um
which shows indeed that the green side
is lower than the left side the red um
that's genes inequality it's a bit more
General than what I just showed here but
that's the main idea how it's used
almost all the time log of an expected
value bigger than an expected value of
the log by the way it's equality if
what's on the inside is constant which
will matter at some point in the future
so um if we keep the thing on the inside
constant it's with equality but if we
don't keep it constant it's an
inequality so you see here we introduce
that
inequality and we end up
with this over here
now this is actually the exact same
thing we had earlier it's what we're
optimizing is the expected value with
respect to sampling from Q um we have
the distribution for Z here that's the
correction factor effectively coming
into play um we have the C given x i um
so the these two are the correction
factor right that's the ratio p over Q
that's the ratio right there and then
this is the other term um so what you
have here circled in green is the
objective that is typically described as
what you optimize to maximize the
likelihood of your data under this
latent variable
model now as I said if we can achieve
equality meaning constant behind the log
um then we have then we have the
tightest bound because instead of bigger
than equal it's equal so we need to do
this Q here is our thing that we get to
choose it's a free choice what our Q is
just like I was before qz given X is a
distribution that we get to choose and
so we're going to add an additional
maximization on the inside here to
maximize our choice for qf of Z
given we can choose anything for it the
best choice I guess will get us the
closest to to the bound and in fact if
we're expressive enough with our qf we
get all the way to equality in fact if
qf if we happen to choose qfz given XI
proportional to the actual or equal to
the actual pz given XI we have equality
and it's a tide
bound why do we care about that well we
started with the idea that we want to
maximize this log probability we found
something that lower bounds it that's
below it so if we also maximize that
we're pushing it up against the thing we
actually care about and then we optimize
the thing we care about more
precisely so I think there's a bit of a
less intuitive derivation it's more like
some some magic going on as one way to
think of it but it gives us effectively
the same result as we have with the
import weighted um
derivation there's yet a third
derivation of the varation lower bound
which will give us yet some additional
inside in it so we're going to see a
third way to get to the same result
we're not doing any new problems um we
just start from the K you say I want to
minimize the K between Q um qz and pz
given X remember that we wanted our qz
to be as close as possible to pz given X
we had a bit more anotation here we
called this Q this this was P Theta Z
given X and this here we actually called
um
Q Z given X um but then and I guess in
this derivation it was shortcut a little
bit right out the K Divergence is an
expectation of the log probability
ratios
um bz given X is a joint divided by the
marginal just write it out
then this last term happened earlier
also and we're got to comment on that
and it's coming back here this last term
here um doesn't depend on Z so what that
means if an expectation over Z of
something that is a constant with
respect to Z that will just be that
constant because the expectation of a
constant is just a constant because you
integrate to one for a proper
distribution here for Z so this stays on
the outside um and then they say oh wow
this is cool what if we now rewrite this
and bring log PX to one side and we put
everything else on the other side okay
and what you see now and I'll add a bit
of
notation as way we had it was a p Theta
here this would a pz Theta x given Z
this we would have been writing as qf Z
given X and this would be P Theta Z
given
X and I'll write this as
qf C given X so matching our previous
notation here what we see is that we
have the same objective that we used to
have in both derivations from
before in the first derivation we said
we also need to
minimize this
KL in the second derivation we said to
make the bound as tight as possible we
got to minimize this KL bring Q5 as
close as possible to P Theta Z given x
what we see here is in some sense what
exactly it all means we see that if
we're optimizing log P Theta given X we
can just optimize this entire thing the
first three terms are the things we've
been working with are optimizing for
Theta and then the second part is we've
been working with Al my per five and we
can see exactly when our bound isn't
holding with equality why it's not is
because the KL is not zero yet between
qf and P Theta for C given X so in some
sense this is the most
comprehensive derivation because it
tells you exactly what you know how
close you are in optimizing P Theta
given X and where you might lose some
Precision in doing so namely you would
lose it in not having a zero K here
which typically would be the case by the
way it's very hard to drive that to
exactly zero because your qf will also
have some regularization will be a
neural network it's function
approximation um which has its benefits
which means that you don't optimize the
exact
likelihood now this is even the most
magical derivation right you just start
from the K you're not even talking about
optimizing your P Theta of X and then
all of a sudden you like swap some
things around and you say this is it um
but this is nice if you write a paper
you just say okay well this is what we
do and you have exactly what we want on
paper there and as you said earlier yeah
if we you know if we don't throw this
part out which we did earlier things
just all end up one optimization problem
and you're exactly
right okay so multiple derivations of
the same thing um how do we not optimize
this for the KL um effectively we sample
from Q um to then
um well let's let's move to here this is
the thing we
optimize this expectation means we
sample so we will sample from Q to get
some z's for each X maybe just one Z in
fact I think that's most often what's
done you sample just one Z for each X
because that's faster and in the next
round you sample a new Z for that same X
and you keep repeating and then you can
um optimize this first
part with respect to Theta and then you
can optimize the second part with
respect to
five
um
okay so now what I haven't told you yet
is how we optimize these different terms
and there's really two different ways to
do
it
um let's start with
the likid ratio gradient so there's two
ways to take derivative through those
objectives the likel ratio gradient and
the reparameterization trick usually
you're going to want to use the
reparameterization trick but it's not as
general as the likelihood ratio gradient
so we'll look at both um so let's see if
I actually have the deration here
because it's just a lot of math to write
out well this is not very high
resolution is it
um yeah let me just rewrite
it so we're looking to
maximize let's say over five
parameterization of our distribution the
expected value when we sample Z from
let's say
qf of Z we know that in our case it's
going to be a qf of Z given X but for
this here we just forget about the X
just to shorten the notation just a
little bit and it's an expected value of
f of
Z you might say okay why don't we sample
some z's right we'll have some Z coming
from
qf of
Z and then we take the gradient respect
to F of 1 / k i = 1 through
k f of
Z I mean that's what we do with
expectation we try to optimize through
an expectation we just sample and then
take the gradient
well doesn't work here why does it not
work
here well look at this gradient that
we're Computing here the FI isn't in
there we're trying to optimize for the
right fi but the FI has just
disappeared because the F lives in the
distribution we sample from qf is what
we sample from we sampled from it and
then we say now this expectation over
you know expected value F of Z let's
optimize our F and it's gone so this gr
will actually be zero but it doesn't
mean we have the right five it just
means we made a mistake a mathematical
mistake all right we can't do what we
just did this is not the way to
go
so what can we do let's take a look at
what this actually means right we're
maximizing over
five again in practice we can't
enumerate all these but you know when we
write out the math we can pretend we can
qf of
c f of
C if I want to take the gradient of this
with respect to five this
thing then I end up with sum over Z gr
respect to F
qf of Z * F of z now I have my qf there
I'm taking the gradient of it it's it's
all looking good only thing I'm now not
not happy with is I have a sum of all
Z's and it could be a lot of Z's and
effectively what this says is um if I
want to approximate this the only way to
approximate this say I'm going to um
have to uniformly sample overall Z which
is probably a pretty bad way to sample
because some z's are more important than
other Z's so we're going to do the same
thing again going say Okay this's a same
as qz over well
um is the same in this case I'm going
use the same one we don't have to use
the same one actually but in this case
it just happens to be that people tend
to use the same
one
um times F of
Z then now I have an expectation of Z
sampled from
qf Z
of
grad f qf c over qf C *
FC which is often then Rewritten as
expectation Z from
qf C grad F log qf of Z time F of Z if
you do reinforce Ming you see this a lot
Q will be a pi um it's the same
idea so what I have now is an
expectation which I could approximate
with sampling I could sample my Z's from
qf right Z I'm going to have my Z come
from qf of Z and then I have my
approximation of 1 over k i = 1 through
k um of gr respect to F
log qf
Z time F of
Z so now I'm doing it correctly this is
a clean way of computing gradients you
might say well how easy to get that grad
log qf zi we choose our qf of Z to be
something we can easily represent
typically Q5 of Z will be a Q5 of Z
given X in our case so it'll be X
mapping through NE Network onto
distribution for Z that's easy to work
with so all these terms are easy to work
with and we can optimize so we're in
good shape at this point which is nice
um so this
became our objective in the simple
scenario of essentially optimizing a
function of this type which is exactly
the type of function we were running
into as we had concluded our derivation
of the importance weighted version as
well as the variational lower bound
version okay that's the low resolution
version of the same
thing so what does it look like
uh as a very simple example I'm going to
try to apply this likel ratio gradient
on a toy problem where I say my
distribution that I'm trying to model
has an unknown mean
mu unit variance so
identity one's on the diagonal matrix
for the for the variance and my
objective that I'm using X here rather
than C but this is the objective f ofx
so what does that mean I'm what I'm
trying to do is try to find a
distribution
that um and I guess we're minimizing
here probably to make it more inter so
we're minimizing this
objective um what that means is that
we're trying to
position um this gaussian right onto the
five five point if I put it right on the
five five point then I'm minimizing the
average deviation of my samples X from
the five5
point with we can read off the solution
obviously you could say okay I know the
solution is 55 but the exercise we're
going through here is if I run the
likelihood ratio policy not policy likid
ratio gradient what happens well what do
I have to do I have to sample for my
current
distribution and then I have to
apply resize then I have to
apply this gradient step over here right
let's inter interet that gradient step
just a little bit what is that gradient
step saying it's
saying I look at the grad log
probability of a sample okay and I'm
trying to increase in this let's say I'm
trying to increase the grad log
probability of a sample if it has a high
score if it's a sample that I like so
samples that are good samples you try to
bring up the probability and samples
that are bad samples Maybe negative
scoring samples you try to bring down
the
probability so that's what's going to be
happening
so we start we s sample in the middle
here sample a bunch of stuff um take a
step we end up over there we sample some
more stuff we end up over there we up
keep going around and it kind of makes
pretty slow progress to get to the
Target wh why is that because as you s
the best they can really do and this is
through many steps is kind of shift
towards your best samples and none of
your best samples were actually at the
Target and so unless you have a sample
that lands right on the target you're
not going to land on the target nothing
in this gradient tells you to go to the
Target it just tells you whichever
samples look best go closer to those and
keep repeating that and so it's a very
gradual optimization doesn't have as
much signal as you would be hoping for
but it's something you can always
do but it might feel pretty
unsatisfactory that this is uh what you
can always do but then doesn't work
super well um here's an
alternative remember um we're trying to
optimize
this parameter fi of a distribution over
Z say that we're optimizing F of
Z and now I'm going to make a very
specific Choice by the way
and we're going to do this by example
but it is more General than this
example I'm going to say
Q5 of Z is a gussan with mean mu and
variance Sigma
squar what that means and this is what
is called the reparameterization trick
is that instead of sampling from this
gausian as something that's some
abstract thing that's happening I can
make it more concrete because I know
what I'm doing here and I can say when I
create a sample what I'm really doing is
I'm creating a z which is equal to Mu
plus Epsilon * Sigma this is 1D just to
keep things simple of course you can do
the math higher dimensional but I'm
trying to get at the core of the
reparameterization trick where Epsilon
comes from normal
okay it's just a way to sample from a
gussan is to do it by sampling from a
unit gussan and then add the mean and
also scale the sample with the standard
deviation okay now if I go back to what
we're trying to do we're trying to
optimize now an
expectation which was over C but really
is well I'll write the original so it's
Z coming
from normal mu Sigma
squ F of
Z but really what we now know this this
is expanation of Epsilon coming from a
normal
01 of f mu + Epsilon time
Sigma okay
now remember that earlier we said we
have an expectation let's just sample
and then take the gradient and it just
made the parameters disappear and it was
a broken way to do it now it's not a
problem because the parameters do not
appear in the sampling process the
reason it was broken because the
parameters we're trying to optimize
we're in the sampling process we first
sample and then optimize the parameters
it's too late but now the parameters are
in the objective here they're not in the
sampling process anymore so now we can
sample we can say this is approximately
equal to 1/ k i from 1 through K of f mu
+ Epsilon
itimes time Sigma where Epsilon I come
from a unit
gussan we can directly optimize this for
Mu n or mu and sigma no problem we did
not hide anything the sampling process
did not have the parameters in it so we
can directly optimize this over
here going back to our example right um
in our example F was really something
along the lines of um we want to be
close to five so would have been 1 over
k i = 1 through K and F was I want to be
as close as possible to five so be mu
plus Epsilon I * Sigma minus 5 it was 2D
but let's ignore that for now if you
look at
this objective here what you're really
seeing is that you're going to push me
to five pretty quickly sure there's a
little bit of noise in it because of the
Epsilon eyes but there's a lot of
signals saying that your mu should go to
five
and if that's really the objective your
Sigma should go to zero actually now
maybe that's not the objective you
really want because it collapses
everything but the signal is very
prominent and the optimization will go
so much faster than with the likel ratio
uh
gradients same thing um now you might
have said hey you're using a gaussian
it's pretty limiting well two
counterpoints to that one counter point
because the derivation definitely uses a
gaou in here right this
reparameterization there are other
distributions that lend themselves to
the same trick and in fact um when we
look at flow models last lecture
essentially what is a flow model it's a
reparameterization trick effectively so
you could put any kind of flow there and
that's okay because the gradient can go
right through so that's one thing to
consider the other thing to consider is
that even though you might say gausian
it's limiting remember why do we even
have a gaus in there it's to land in a
simple space we want to go from a
complex X space to a simple zspace and
maybe the fact that we put a gaus in
there is a positive rather than a
negative to end up with a good simpler
representation of our data um so two
reasons why this is actually much more
General than it might seem at first and
it is also what's uh very often used in
today's most popular versions use some
quantization tricks on top of this that
make it more robust more sharp in some
sense the images you get out but it's
kind of the same idea reparameterization
trick going through the quantization
step I think Kevin will probably say
something about it later when looking at
the vector quantized VA
so well this is just a I guess a typ Sit
version of what we looked at it's saying
that if we're trying to optimize an
expectation respect to a gussan um and
we're optimizing the parameters of the
gaussian we can um convert it into a
unit gussan uh with respect to which we
take the expectation and then have a
direct optimization of the parameters of
the
gaussian so let's go back to our toy
problem we want this thing to go to five
five um with a pathwise derivative
essentially which is like move in the
right direction step by step this of
course depends on the step size of our
gradient updates but we don't hop around
it's not like where did my most lucky
sample end up Landing let's move over
there and then where's my now most lucky
sample let's move over there it's
actually seeing the gradient towards
where the mean is supposed to be and
keeps moving directly in that
direction
um let's see okay um
let's let's go back to what we had right
we had
our varation Auto encoder equation which
consisted of um the terms well we
were're maximizing over Theta and fi and
we had the variational lower bound which
is this thing over here that we're
optimizing um which is an expectation
with respect to qf we're sampling our
Z's um we now have a choice do we apply
the likelihood ratio gradient or do we
apply the reparameterization trick
gradient we know that it depends on what
distribution our qf is if it's a
gaussian we can apply the
reparameterization trick if it's a
binary distribution like binomial we
can't apply there's no
reparameterization trick for that we
might have to use the likud ratio
gradient so let's look at the likel
ratio gradient first what is end up
looking as um it really pops up over
here as we're optimizing this file
um for our variational distribution Q um
it's essentially the slide I mean I
think we we have so much to cover that
we can maybe go through the details
after lecture who wants to on their own
but essentially what we're doing is
we're applying that same idea of um
likel ratio gradient now to this
specific objective um as you work
through it what you end up with um you
end up with this
part over here
question um end up with this part over
here you sample you have a uh grad log
probability of Z given x i which then
gets multiplied into your objective um
so it's and the objective here is this
this part on the top here so and then
the second part which on the slide is
saying actually if you work out the math
it kind of disappears it it kind of
cancels out to a gradient of zero so you
can work you you going to essentially
just sample your z's look at the grad
log probability respect to q and then
multiply with the objective to get um
your optimization problem for fi and
then your optimization problem for Theta
is very simple you have your samples
from qf and you just maximize log
probability of X with respect to given Z
so
that's one way to do it um is General
the way it's usually done um is using
the pathwise
um derivation let's skip these slides um
and so in this case devation lower bound
essentially comes down to that you will
see sampling from a unit gaussian uh
instead of from some arbitrary Q the
parameters will be worked into the
objective and you get one big objective
that you optimize as you're trying to uh
compute the best fs and
qes let's see um yeah let's give some
examples and then take it take a break
um so your qf Z given X will now
typically be a essentially a neural
network will be under the hood that goes
from X to the MU and the sigma fi um and
then in the other Direction there is
your P Theta x given
Z the reason it's called an auto encoder
is because essentially you turn your X
into a z and then get back out X and
that's what Auto encoders refer to um is
that you somehow ideally compress your
data and then recover it back out
there's other ones like Den noising Auto
encoders where you um put noise along
the way um very in very specific ways or
maybe even on the X you put noise this
one can also be thought of as actually
putting noise on on your um embedding
because really what happens if you look
at the details as you go from X to Z
usually it's designed in the simplest
cases to be a deterministic mapping from
X to mu and sigma but then your Z is
sampled from this distribution so really
what's happening is you get a mu and
sigma and because you sample your Z
there's a little bit of noise you're not
exactly landing on me you're Landing
somewhere around there and then you have
to decode back onto X and you can say
well that's annoying that the noise pops
up there but at least my intuition is
it's actually a feature because that
noise is actually ensuring that in the
embedding B embedding space z if you
move around just a little bit there the
result X should remain the same you can
have a totally different X when you just
move a little bit because then you would
never recover the correct X during
training and so another way that just
discards all these derivations to think
of the VA I'm not saying it's the right
way the nice thing about derivation is
that you have an objective you know that
when the you know objectiv is being
optimized you're doing better and better
and better there's compression tied to
it but if you want to just be like super
simple and intuitive about it you say I
have a neural network let me erase
everything for a second if you want to
be maximally simple about it you just
say I have a Neal Network that goes from
X to
Z then I put noise in Z space a little
bit of you know noise in zspace and then
have to be able to recover X still and
the reason I like it is because it means
that my embeddings have to be such that
nearby embeddings must have a simal
meaning in xace otherwise I couldn't do
this back and forth this way and that's
it that's that's another way to get to
vae um without any of the formal
derivations then the question becomes
well you know if that's the only
intuition you have well are you really
optimizing an objective what are you
doing like how do you measure meas the
errors on X and so forth and if you run
your optimization you know you're
improving on an objective if you don't
know that then it's hard to debug things
so that's why it's nice to have all the
formalities because you know that your
optimization is correctly set up but
probably the highest level intuition of
why these embeddings are good and
meaningful is just that embed put noise
and you got to recover the original so
locally things cannot change much much
if you change in your embedding space
locally things cannot change much in
xace VA at the time when the paper came
out it's a while ago now it must been
2013 or 14 something
um was compared with the Wake sleep
algorithm which was the best algorithm
at the time is not popular at all these
days uh and was outperforming it which
made made it a big deal that was
possible to outperform it um you see
consistently the red curves doing better
than the green curves um on some you
know simple data sets at the time and
mist and some simple face data sets um
Mist digit generation with the vae at
the time this was a big deal this is not
today's age where we can create any kind
of deep fix that we want this is like
wow you can actually generate images
that look like handwritten digits by
just sampling uh from this vae and the
interpolations are nice you pick you
know a
few extremes and you interpolate in
latent space and you see that you get
you know a nice nice progression between
the different kinds of
digits I'll skip this oh well I'll
briefly say something here at the time
it came out the ve did not get the same
um likelihood scores as autoaggressive
model autog models are in some sense
more focused on maximizing the log
probability and tend to score a bit
better at it but then the Vees have to
do this work to put things into a latent
space where then noise is introduced so
there's kind of more work for them to do
which might lead to better
representations but doesn't always give
the same uh great uh likelihood scores
or bits per dim type scores um but it
gets
close um we talked about you know why is
it auto encoder there's a reconstruction
loss to go from Z back to X and it is
then the regularization to keep your
distribution for Z close to a prior that
you imposed for z um that uh ensures
that you have a nice yeah I think Peter
gave a nice kind of motivation for why
the VA exists and different ways you can
arrive at it U the second part of the
lecture will be most mostly variations
on on the simple VA so we'll go over a
bit how this looks like um
implementation wise or like practically
speaking and then go on to to discuss
different options we can do to tweet
different parts of the
VA um so maybe one thing we can do first
is just kind of go over from a from like
a system point of view what a what a VA
looks like so at the top is what we do
during training so X here is kind of the
data distribution so it's your your set
of images for example uh and we're
trying to discover this this latent
variable z uh that kind of correlates to
this image so there there are kind of
multiple motivations for for why people
use VES in practice one of them is if
you just want a generative model so if
we want a generative model it's saying
we want to just be able to generate
basically new images from nothing that
fit the distribution um another kind of
motivation is sometimes you you just
care about C so sometimes we like having
a latent variable that represents an
image is nice because you can condition
another neural network on it or you can
do some manipulations in Z space that
then transfer to manipulation in image
space so there's kind of two two main
components of the VA which is using it
as a generative model and also as a
representation learning
Tool uh and the derivations that we went
over in the first half of the lecture uh
end up leaving us with these two losses
over here here see if I can write yes
okay so we have the the Reconstruction
loss which is basically
maximizing uh the log probability of the
data uh um using Z's that are not
actually generated from from uh the the
true prior but this approximation Q
so because we're using an approximation
Q of Z given X instead of the real P of
Z given X we also have this
regularization term which basically says
just make sure that Q of Z given X is is
close to what you would get if you
applied Bas rule to the real p and of
course as we as we saw before the real p
is intractable we can't sample from it
so we use uh this approximation instead
so the idea is yeah you you can train
here on images from your from your data
set or I mean not just images other
things as well U optimizing these two
objectives so once we have this if we
want to sample from this model uh we can
just discard the encoder so during
sampling time we don't know what our
images look like right we want to
generate new ones so intuitively that's
saying okay well we don't need this
first part here we're just going to
sample Z's from our prior
distribution and in the in the
derivations before we used the unit gion
so this is basically saying during
training we we sample Z's from from this
which uh is not really the uni gussion
it's actually just um Z's that are
likely to come from X but we have this
regularization term so Q is like the
unit gion okay and during sampling time
we we substitute in the true unit gion
here and try to generate samples from
that so kind of a high level this is how
you train a VA this is how you would use
it during
sampler uh and we can use this and it
kind of works on in a in a bunch of
different ways um so this is some
results generating uh faces from a ve
and it's kind of nice so these are all
random faces that kind of look like
faces from the data set but aren't
actually from there uh and kind of a
cheap way which we haven't shown here to
to verify if it's memorizing or not is
to look up the nearest neighbor in the
data set so something you can do as a
sanity check this might be helpful is
look up like take one take a sample and
just try to find the closest sample in
the data set if they match exactly
you're doing something wrong it's just
memorizing or it's overfitting but if
these images kind of look natural but
there's not exact clones uh then then
that's on the right
track and you'll notice that vaes work
pretty well in set things
where the images follow some sort of
form so in all these faces there's kind
of uh the faces rotate they move around
but all the eyes are centered uh in the
same place and and that's kind of coming
from the fact that you have to represent
a face in this in this case in like a
for example a 16 dimensional latent
Vector there's not much info you can get
there in fact because we assume latent
Vector is a Goan all the dimensions are
independent which even limits even more
the kind of info that you can you can
can represent in your
space uh but then but the nice thing
about discussion inter interpretation is
we can do
interpolation um this this was supposed
to be a video that didn't really work
but as you saw in the M slides earlier
you can basically take one image
generated from a VA and and smoothly
interpolate it until it looks like a
different image and the reason this
works is because the images are
represented as points sampled from the
unit gion and we know that in a unit
gion distribution
uh there's kind of high probability Mass
between any linear combination of points
they stay within the kind of high
probability regions so if you take any
two points in zspace and linearly
interpolate um you can be confident
you're still within the
support doesn't matter what do you
follow in some sense the the curvature
meaning interpolate on a sphere surface
of a sphere versus keeping the norm
constant just go right through it there
might be some empirical reasons why why
so in in theory it it shouldn't matter
because um basically any convex
combination of points within the unit
auction will um stay within the I guess
the the the least probable point is the
least lower the least probable Point
you'll encounter on the path so at least
your Z space will remain within kind of
the high log likelihood
space um so but there might be some some
kind of numerical reasons why that's
true I don't know off the top about that
uh so this is some nice things we get
from the unic aan so the unican has a
lot of nice properties uh but it turns
out we can use we can use different
things uh and the fact here is like pz
is is this prior design choice so we we
derve the whole vae using a generic
prior and we kind of assume that well
let's use a unican has a lot of nice
properties but we can experiment with
different ideas and a lot of the
extensions on on how vaes work today uh
use different choices on what pfz can
be so first let's kind of think about
why we use the unit gion or the unit
normal here well one thing is there's
this nice analytic form and uh it's very
easy to compute the K Divergence between
uh two gausian we we can take this
without sampling we can calculate
essentially it's a term involving the
mean and then the log standard
deviation um and yeah as as I said
before we can do these nice linear
interpolations uh because the space is
kind of well behaved so points within
that space are points that are close
within the space generally are close um
in the output
distribution but we have this this one
downside which is the dimensions are all
independent so when I'm sampling Z's
from the unit gussion the the sample on
the second dimension does not depend on
the first uh which means that for
example if I'm sampling a face and I
know my this First Dimension tells me my
face is is turned the second dimension
maybe it corresponds to to ears but one
of the ears is hidden uh you're going to
have weird Behavior if you to sample you
know a certain kind of ear when the face
is turned so so you don't get to take
into account uh prior other dimensions
which is kind of something unsatisfying
about the
unitor uh and so this introduces some
this this NV paper basically Builds on
these idea of hierarchical vaes where
the idea is we can actually learn more
expressive
distributions of P of Z and in this case
what we want to do is we want to learn
two networks actually we want to learn
uh P of Z and we want to learn this Q of
uh Z given X and we want those
distributions to be close uh in KL so
that when we sample from uh P of Z it's
it's equivalent to sampling from from Q
ofz given X but it's actually uh the the
form of these two distributions can be
up in the air they can be essentially uh
chosen to be whatever we want as long as
the K Divergence between them is SL so
one option to do this is well we can
sample Z's autor regressive so imagine
our prior distribution is actually a
neural network where we first uh sample
zf1 maybe from from aashian and then we
sample Z2 conditioned on Z1 and Z3
conditioned on everything before and so
this is kind of what we talked about in
in the lecture two on on auto regressive
models uh and so how do we do this well
we can still use the the gsh we just
used the UN we just used the gussion
where the the mean and standard
deviation are conditioned on the sample
of the previous
imion uh it turns out that there's some
certain instabilities that come if you
just do this naively so if we just have
a two a of regressive models one for p
and one for Q uh even though we enforce
that KL similar um actually getting that
KL lost to to converge is quite tricky
so in practice we use this residual Norm
which is uh a trick from this
NV so the idea of the residual normal is
well we can define a normal distribution
as a normal distribution on top of of
another normal distribution so you
sample you know one thing from
distribution one and then you sample
another normal on top of that so using
the output of that as the mean uh and so
what we do here is we have our prior
defined by P so our prior defines this
sort of distribution here and then Q is
defined as a residual on top of that so
basically take take the mean uh outputed
here from from here and add this Delta
term and we take the standard deviation
and uh for standard deviation you
multiply the Delta
ter uh and then the nice thing about
this is we get we get back this this
analytic K diversion again so one of the
nice things about using the gashing is
we have this this we can calculate the
KL over the entire distribution without
sampling it because we know the form
well if you define these things as
residuals uh we get this back again
uh and then kind of one Insight here is
that uh the residual
normal comment on what's the problem
with not doing the residual yeah the
problem with not doing the residual is
that and this is explained a bit more in
the papers uh if these distributions are
kind of wildly different so if if if
this distribution has like a you know a
mu of of five and here we have mu
of5 uh then the gradient between these
two becomes really numerically unstable
so
the kind of the K between these two
becomes very high uh and that leads to
basically bad numerical property so it's
nice if uh if both of these
distributions kind of look close to each
other yeah so kind of one way way to
look at this is let's say the I I've
already sampled Z1 so Z1 is is some some
valid some real number say. five then
now what I want to do is p of Z2 given
Z1 which we're defining as kind of this
normal variable where let's say the mean
is is one and the standard deviation is
is also
one uh but now what I want to do is kind
of Define Z2 given Z1 and X where X is
is the image
so one way to do it is to try and match
match this distribution by also
outputting this U but the other way to
do it is to Output just the like one
plus something and one times something
here that's basically just saying like
the the the like the distribution with
with knowledge of the the underlying
image is just a a kind of transformation
over the prior
distribution uh and and this is a
generalization of if your P of if your
pror distribution P here is just the the
normal with mu0 standard deviation one
um then this is actually just a
generalization of the the original VA
term so your Delta terms just become the
regular mean and standard
Dev um so this is one way to do to add a
more powerful prior so in this case P of
Z given the previous are our learn so
during sampling time uh you would not
sample your entire like a latent
Dimension latent variable at once but
you would use this Auto regressive
sampling to sample one dimension at a
time uh and then you would decode your
image from
there uh so okay what else can we do for
our prior distributions well one answer
is that we've been we've been looking
mostly at continuous distributions which
kind of makes sense because we can
Define flows on them we can kind of uh
they have some nice properties but there
are also nice properties that come with
discret distributions and one of the
most powerful ones is it's very easy to
to Define expressive distributions as as
categoricals um in continuous space
we'll usually use uh the gausian
distribution but it's hard to Define for
example a gan distribution with with two
modes or two um whereas in discret space
we can do all sorts of fancy things
because we don't have to worry too much
about um defining the entire
space
uh and the other nice thing is is the
the capacity of Z is bounded I'll
explain a little bit more about what
this means but it basically means uh
even if we don't know the the the actual
form of pz we can we can kind of get a
bound on this KL term so we can know at
least in the worst case how how much off
we
are so that that introduces vqv uh this
is a model that you'll hear a lot so if
you if you read recent papers it's it's
proven to be quite powerful uh and the
original paper is it's not exactly a vae
so start to jump in can you go back for
a moment
yeah one
more I wonder if part of the rationale
here is you UL you want to sample from
pz right new samples and then by
training this way you have maximum
parameter sharing yeah between the Z
given X and the Z given Z right
like so
there's it's a higher chance that I
guess you you learn the right thing
rather than require to train two
separate things yeah yeah so so what
Peter is saying here is if we Define um
Q just as a as a residual over P well
then like naturally we're kind of
training both of the networks at the
same time if p is outputting a correct
um Auto regressive distribution so
during sampling time we discard Q so it
kind of doesn't make sense for Q having
to model p and additional stuff whereas
if we can say p is or Q is kind of
additional information you know using
the output of P um we can kind of use P
during training time and and share that
that that
compute uh yeah so back to vqv so this
is this is kind of a model of of how the
architecture works and and the caveat
here is
yeah it's not exactly a VA so we'll
we'll we'll kind of glance over the the
K loss part so for this first part just
focus mostly on this uh on this
reconstruction loss here so let's focus
on yeah on this part here and this K
part we we'll talk about that in a
little
bit uh but the basic intuition between
the vqv is what if we have Z instead of
being continuous vector be a set of of
code words so here we we learn this we
have this Matrix here of let's say uh K
different words or k different code
words where a code word is just a vector
uh and then the dimension here is maybe
D uh the idea is to map from your input
image to a set of code wordss uh that
then decode into that
image so normally we don't just have one
code word we would have for example um
we would have like this Matrix so let's
say a 32x 32 image would map to let's
say a 4x4 Matrix of of code words with
one Matrix or one word in in each
Square uh and then and the idea is if
you map your image into these discrete
tokens it's kind of naturally the the
you you kind of naturally learn this
compressed form of the image because in
a continuous space you can kind of model
arbitrary amounts of info here we're
kind of enforcing that the the
information in the image needs to be
limited to this this combination of
tokens and so if we can recreate the
image from those tokens we know that
they're they're learning something
correct how do you choose the value of K
for your problem is there any way to
find maybe a minimum value to certain
performance uh so K is largely a hyper
parameter I think I I don't know off the
top of my head if there are some like
Justified ways to choose K I think kind
of a empirical way to choose K is the
larger your K gets probably the the
better you'll be able to recreate your
image um but at some point your your
samples from when you're trying to
sample from this distribution will get
worse so you can imagine at the case
where K is at Infinity uh it becomes
very hard to to sample images that
actually uh fit the so the the prior so
there's kind of this trade-off between
if K is really high well it's easy to
get high log likelihoods U but you're
you're kind of KL Divergence between
your prior and and what you sample for
will get will get
higher
so what does uh yeah this is kind of
just some more some more intuition on
what the VQ VA is doing how does our VA
look if we if we interpret it as in the
VQ version well this distribution here
becomes a deterministic distribution so
the way it works is let's talk about one
case where we just pick uh one vector
for each image or one code book for each
image one code word for each
uh we would basically take our image
compress it down into the lat space with
the neural network and pick the code
word that's the closest to the output of
that Network and so you can kind of
imagine this as a deterministic
distribution where we assign a
probability of one uh to the vector
that's the closest to the image and zero
to every other
Vector um and that means that this kind
of KL term if we assume a uniform
distribution over the vectors as our
prior
um is kind of bounded by this this log K
term so we can say some things about
kind of how much our log probabilties
match the true log probabilities based
on the fact that uh that we're bounded
by this uh discrete
space yeah okay I was this slide got a
little bit messed up um maybe what I can
do is I will just I'll just write what
what this is saying here but this is
this is kind this slide kind of answers
a question of how do you actually
optimize discret space so this is kind
of when when you first look at these
ideas it's kind of unclear how
to how to handle the fact that we're
tokenizing because you know gradients
are usually defined on continuous spaces
um how can we
actually how can we do this uh in a
space that that's discrete so let me
just write this term down
here
so there's kind of three terms that we
have to use uh in conjunction in the
normal VA we only have this term right
this is just the the log likelihood of
the data so that's still
there um with the caveat that we use
this that's straight through
optimization trick so if you ever hear
someone say we use the the straight
through trick or the straight through
optimizer um what it means
is when you take your image X you'll
first map it to some some predicted
latent Vector let's say I call it Z
Prime uh and then we'll find the closest
code book which is the closest code word
that that's matches the C which we'll
call Z and then from this C we'll then
decode X Prime now but there's a jump
these two z's are not exactly the same
so how do you handle this uh it turns
out in practice what you do is you
calculate the gra gradient with respect
uh to Z but then you uh just transfer it
over to to Z Prime and and in the
homework we we'll show you basically
exactly what this means in terms of P
torch code it's actually very simple to
do but the basic idea is to just kind of
assume that these vectors are very close
together and take the gradient
pretending one vector is the
other uh and then these these other two
terms here just help this process work
better so this embedding loss here um SG
here means
the the stop gradient operator so in
this case we would take the the gradient
with respect to to e here and ignore the
gradient with respect to Z here um yeah
what this is saying
here uh is that sorry I know this this
little this is e here in this notation
and this is z
ofx what this term is saying is uh for I
need to somehow optimize the code book
words to to be close to what the what
this encoder here is out putting it's
basically saying move this Vector close
to that uh and then the commitment loss
is basically saying well move this
Vector close to
that um and there there's a term on this
there's some kind of way to balance it
in practice this term doesn't matter too
much so I think this kind of stuff is
better understood implementing it but
the high level idea is um how do you
optimize through the discret operator uh
just take just kind of assume that that
your discrete jump is not very big and
have these two terms to penalize that
jump for being
good a littleit
yes quickly gra the pen think one
another way way I like to think of it is
that if you go from
X to your Z Prime as given had it's just
an alternative way to think of it in a
standard Auto encoder you would then go
from Z prime or standard VI you would go
to essentially this here think of as
your mu of X right your mu of X would
really go to Mu of X Plus Epsilon time
Sigma that's what a standard ve would do
and in this Vector quantize VA the way
you can think of it is essentially that
you look at the surrounding means and
the surrounding means that you get to
choose from So You Look At You know one
through K and that determines your
choice of Epsilon so instead of sampling
Epsilon from
normal your Epsilon becomes essentially
as I try to round onto a nearby thing
what AM how much am I rounding and that
process tells you what your Epsilon is
so and once you think of it that way you
can it's like a standard VA is just you
don't sample the gaussian to get the
Epsilon you just do that process of
where's my nearest neighbor and that
that Delta is my Epsilon and now I can
Infuse it the same way and everything
everything works the same way I mean you
still need to do the other two terms but
it's just another way to think about
what's happening and why the gradients
can just go
through cool yeah thanks
Peter um okay so one kind of additional
step you need to do in in the vqv
is when we're um when we're learning
this kind of encoding from from from uh
X to
Z the this distribution of of kind of
this distribution Q of of Z given X here
uh it's not uniform right some some
tokens will be used more than other
tokens uh and so if we try to sample
from Q of Z given X uniformly we're
actually going to get samples that do
not match the the data distribution uh
what we need to do is we need to to
train our prior a pfz to match this kind
of data condition prior of of um Q of Z
given X I guess uh you know times P of x
from from the data so it is kind of one
way to think of this is kind of a a
reverse form of what we do uh in a
normal VA so in a normal VA we Define
our prior first and we make sure that
this uh encoder Q of Z given X matches
our prior uh in the bqv we kind of
learned the encoder first and then after
the fact we learn our prior to match
what the encoder has like
and the nice thing is that pfz here we
we can again choose it to be anything we
want and so we can plug in our favorite
generative model um as this kind of
Prior learn so in the original vqv and
and vqv 2 papers they used the pixel CNN
which you worked on in homework one uh
and in these days um we tend to use
models like a Transformer or or a
diffusion model which we'll cover later
over that c space but the basic idea
here is uh first you learn your your
tokens so you learn tokens that help
kind of compress an image into the lat
space and then learn a prior over the
tokens and often these two things are
are decoupled so you can do one first
and then the
other uh so yeah here's some examples on
vqv uh and we can see like vqv was kind
of a a nice leap in performance from
what we could do with the the standard
VI the images we generate here are a lot
more like crisp and clear compared to
when we had to map them onto the unit
gion part of that intuitively is that
the the unit gion enforces this kind of
smoothness uh between the lat and space
and and the images whereas in reality
images are actually they have a lot of
edges they have a lot of harder
transitions uh and the discrete tokens
kind of help um model
that um yeah so here's some more
examples of the vqv sampling
images um they're they're still not
perfect and I think bqv models today are
are getting even better than this so you
can see like from a distance they look
good um if you look closely enough
you'll realize some of the some of the
bodies don't look quite right uh and and
part of that is the fact that our latent
space in the vqv is still kind of uh
spatial so relationships between
different spatial areas of the image are
still kind of disentangled which is
which is nice in some ways like uh
usually the the bottom corner is not as
the bottom corner still contains more
information about its local neighbors
than the top but in cases where you have
the body of an animal actually you do
need those spatial relationships and
sometimes those things can get
lost so yeah vqv 2.0 uh is basically
just the kind of the improvements over
the original vqv model I I think there's
not too much in terms of of things we
need to go over for this other than the
fact that this exists so if you're
trying to implement vqv take a look at
what they do in two and usually the
tricks here will will help improve your
your
training uh but here are some here are
some examples of things generated from
from vqv
2.0 uh the nice so kind of one other
nice thing about uh these vqv models and
and specific models that decouple your
prior versus your uh encoder decoder is
it's easier to do conditional generation
so in this case these images are
actually conditional on on image net CET
so over here we're trying to generate uh
docks or dogs over here uh and then the
nice thing is we can learn our encoder
and decoder in an unconditional way uh
and we only have to train our prior in a
conditional way which kind of again it
decouples this process so you can do a
lot of heavy lifting mapping your raw
pixel images to tokens uh and then you
can just gener generate tokens uh with a
conditional PR so the same way in
homework one we did the the text to to
image with the Transformer you can do
that same sort of thing here where we're
generating uh tokens
instead um yeah and then finally one one
nice thing about the vae which we I I'll
talk briefly about it here I think we'll
talk about it more in in a future
lecture is that they don't s they don't
suffer as much about this problem of of
mode coverage so one one thing you'll
see I think in next week's lecture with
about Gans is that certain types of
generative models tend to collapse to
certain modes so so one kind of way to
think about this is if my image data set
has 10 images um the VA has to give a
high probability to every single one of
those images whereas other types of
models such as such as the Gan maybe it
can give very high probabilities to half
of them and ignore the other
half uh which means that all your images
will look good but they won't be very
diverse you can see here that the Gan
generated images all kind of share the
same pose whereas the VA images have
things in a lot of different
positions so we will talk about this a
little bit more but one intuition about
the vae and and likelihood based models
is that they do try to model exactly the
the data
distribution um yeah here are some more
examples of of the diversity
here um yeah again here you can see
different zoomed in forms you can see
different different
angles yeah in comparison to over there
this is big Gan which is one of the
state-of-the-art Gan
models uh yeah and then kind of one one
concluding comment here uh is that
largely vaes have not changed too much
since uh in the last few years I think
advances have have happened pretty
dramatically in in the other generative
models um but V are still used pretty
reliably as a building block for kind of
other types of of generative
modeling uh basically a a lot of the the
the state-of-the-art image generation
methods today still use a VA to do that
that initial processing so VQ which
we'll talk about next week builds off
the vqv and then stable diffusion uses a
vae to to map images to a lat space
first and then we'll and then tries to
model that that Laten space first same
with this Cog view which basically does
uh a text to image Transformer on the
lat and space where that space is first
learned from the VA so one intuition to
take away is you can use the VA to just
learn this really good mapping from X to
Z Z back to X and then if you can model
P of X you kind of already have your
model or if you can model P of Z you
already have your model for for p of
[Music]
X um so yeah that's that's kind of the
end of the the variation setting since
we have a little a bit more time we can
talk about some kind of other ways to
look at V one way is this kind of just
this view of mutual information which
might be
[Music]
helpful um so the mutual information
between two variables is is defined as
this it's basically the entropy of uh
your X distribution minus the the
conditional entropy and you can compute
it either
way and if we're modeling data sets
usually this is fixed so if you have
access a space of images well you're not
going to change the the entropy of your
underlying data it's it's just there but
what we can do is we can uh we can
improve this term so we can improve uh
basically reduce the entropy of your
data conditioned on on some some
variable y so y you can think of Y as as
Z in the other case that's kind of the
relation
here um and and mutual information is is
kind of a does not use any form of of
linearity so covariance is kind of one
way to to look at relations between two
variables but it depends a lot on
basically the the linear relationship
between
them um and so in a lot of papers you
might read you'll refer to um or they'll
they'll mention Mutual information and
they'll mention um basically maximizing
Mutual information between one variable
and another and so the the trick to
understand is just vaes are one way to
to do Mutual information
maximization
um and the explanation here
is um so so these actual entropies are
are
interactable um basically this is saying
like the the the the true Mutual
information between two variables is
kind of the the best case decoder so if
you had the optimal way to predict uh X
from Z or in this case Z from X that's
what your Mutual information would be um
we don't know if our model is is the
best so the best we can do is is an is
aound on it so the best we can do is
basically abound saying uh if I can
provide you an encoder that can predict
X to this degree I kind of have a a
certificate that the mutual information
is at least that number although the
true one could be
higher uh and so kind of the derivation
here should look very similar to what we
saw before basically we can uh encode Z
using using p so in this slides p and Q
is is swapped sometimes that happens
um uh but this should look very similar
to basically the derivation of the VA we
learned before because the VA is
essentially optimizing some bound on the
mutual information between Z and the the
underlying data
distribution um I think that's I'm going
to skip a few of these I wanted to just
talk about this beta ve as one final one
final
thing um earlier in the earlier in the
presentation we talked about how the VA
actually achieves two things so it's a
generative model but it's also a way to
learn representations and sometimes you
care about one thing more than the other
uh and in cases like that sometimes it's
good to just do this thing where you add
this this beta term here so it's it's a
very simple change uh but the basic idea
is adding this term here lets you
trade-off between how well I'm
recreating my image and how well um
that's that zspace is compressed so
sometimes we care more about having z um
be a be a fully compressive thing than
we care about the actual uh image
generation quality and sometimes vice
versa so this is just another helpful
thing to to play with if you're training
VA models sometimes it's helpful to add
this beta term in here play with
different values if you care about one
objective or the
other uh and then the experiments here
show that if you if you tune this beta
parameter we can get latent spaces that
actually make sense so this is in the in
the gausa Laten space you take one of
the dimensions um or basically a linear
Direction in those directions uh and
just add that to a sample Z and some of
those directions correspond to to actual
semantically meaningful things so we can
kind of find a a Delta and Z that
corresponds to to color or to to gender
or to to other things so in this case
they beta to be higher or lower in
general to to get this experiment I
don't know off the top of my head so I
don't want to say the wrong answer um
it's in it's in the paper
yeah
um yeah I think I think that's it so
that's kind of just a quick
overview back
to how do you
deter how do you determine K in the in
the
vqv so again K is is kind of a
hyperparameter you want to decide ahead
of time
there are some intuitions between why
you would choose a lower k or a higher K
and the basic trade-off is if your K is
higher you will likely get better
Recreation during training but it will
also be harder to model that that prior
distribution pfz uh
later if um something can be modeled
with a smaller K it more computationally
simple is it less complex it
can I think there I think there is
something you can say about it again I
don't know off the top of my head but uh
one way to think about K is that it's
discrete bits so if I can com if I can
compress the full contents of a
distribution into a set of bits um then
I kind of have some some notion of know
this data set contains this much entropy
so if you can in a Lo in a lossless way
compress into
actual discret bits then you have you
have a real bound otherwise it's kind of
just an intuitive like if I can get you
know this level of of likelihood with a
small k then I kind of have a simpler
distribution add one
thing um since we didn't cover it but um
it might be worth quickly saying
something about the variational loss
Auto encoder and the pixel VA
essentially that line will work what
that's saying is imagine you have a vae
and you have a encoder decoder and you
make your
decoder very very large extremely large
and very expressive let's say you make
an extreme decod that's an
autoaggressive model
itself then if you look at the bounds
what will happen is that um you have
such an expressive decoder it will
ignore Z it will just generate one pixel
at a time because anytime it does
anything with Z it's lossy because
there's noise introduced on Z so it's
going to do less while reconstruction
and so some of the things that you um
that becomes surprising once you put a
super expressive autoaggressive model as
a decoder is that you actually have to
handicap it to make sure it still uses
the Z codes by doing Dropout or reducing
the the depth or anything like that so
even though in principle you can just
combine all these things together
there can be some unexpected side
effects so put a full autor model as uh
x given Z all of a sudden it'll ignore Z
and that's that's a problem of course is
now your Z doesn't doesn't mean anything
anymore um so that that's kind of one
one interesting thing that um that I I
guess um is good to be aware of and if
you want to dive deeper the variational
loss the auto encoder and the pixel VA
papers um take a look at that and what
you can do to to resolve that
issue yeah I think it related to to the
prev so if you tune beta to be super
large yeah and you have very expressive
de so the solution of that is the K will
be zero basically you say that the
encoder will predict mean of zero and
VAR
which means that your lat has no
information at all yeah
and so that means the basically the if
you satisfy the the VA objective
perfectly you have a perfectly bad
model is that true yeah so if you have B
go to let's say like Infinity um then
the information in Z has to be zero so Z
has to perfectly match the the unic
caution which means it's uninform
and in that case you're just trying to
to model P of P of X directly basically
what we were doing back in the in the
auto regressive function so if you think
about the the performance of of a model
that has no kind of information about
the original X it will be less it will
have worse log likelihoods than the
model that can um that can condition on
Z on an informative Z but depending on
the beta term like the TR off between
how how expensive that that comput that
information is in terms of the loss and
your log your log likelihoods change so
the fact that we have interpretable or
interpretable latent space is the side
effect of imperfect
model yeah so one way to think about um
B is it's as a something that encourages
compression so I can maybe like the the
age variable for example if I had
infinite capacity I would describe it as
five independent variables it would be
like the color of my hair and then the
how thin my face is uh but uh if if I'm
penalized for leaking information
through Z those things are actually
correlated so it makes sense to
represent them instead as as one
dimension and so that has the side
effects of leading to a kind of more
interpretable uh behavior in latent
space because things that are more
correlated in the data have to be merged
into into single kind of
directions
uh question about like the decoder being
too expressive I guess um what is the
problem here like I guess if the decoder
doesn't really look at Z how is it able
to reconstruct the input itself so yeah
so the same way that we we we
implemented things uh in the
autoaggressive lecture where we can
decode an image completely
unconditionally uh you can get some I
mean there are ways to basically model
distribution without using the inherent
latent variable uh they just won't be as
good because if you have some hints
about what your your actual image was
you can decode it a lot better than if
you have to decode based on the
expectation over your whole
data so kind of one one kind of further
intuition for for the issue with the
powerful decoder is there is a bit of a
a chicken and egg problem where if the
decoder learns to ignore Z then no
gradients will kind of flow into the
encoder and so the encoder will have no
signal to then to even try to encode
information which means even if the kind
of global maximum of my objective is to
have some information there uh if the
decoder is too powerful that signal will
not propagate down to the encoder so
you'll end up in a space where where you
don't want to be you're essentially just
converging to sort of the mean of the
dist not not exactly the mean but the
the kind of unconditional probability of
the that
dat what if we were attending TOA not
continu like something stru for
example yeah I think there there are
ways you can do that
so the the the encoder and decoder
distributions don't have to be
continuous so in image spaces they're
continuous because images are continuous
um you can definitely have your decoder
output for example uh a discrete
distribution over possible tokens right
that's something you could do your input
can Al condition on these discrete
tokens and you can compute log
probabilities the way you always would
so basically the answer is if you can if
you can still write down your data and
and calculate the the probabilities of
that data with your model you can use
the VA setup and there's there I'm sure
there are some specialized things for
graphs for example that